[Music]
here we've got your soulmate options
calendar real Islander and a theoretical
third person let's call her as
strawberry mango twist okay close your
eyes
think about each of the women open your
eyes
the answer is real Eleanor how do you
know I don't but the minute I said that
you knew instinctively whether it felt
right well hang on let me think about
that how's it know
no more thinking GD just do something
indecision cost you so much agony in
your life right up to the very end I had
a little trouble writing my speech I
wrote 11 different versions weddings in
20 minutes buddy oh boy I mean please
run about 55 minutes apiece I'm really
hot is this air conditioner even working
yes it is you're just having a literal
meltdown also you're not dressed yet and
we haven't picked up the ring okay well
uh there's an issue there involving what
I consider to be unfair labor practices
on the part of the jeweler and we never
had a bachelor party because you can
never settle on a location or time I'm
sorry you were right this is too much
for me you should just leave me here and
go get married yeah here's the thing but
my wedding isn't for another month this
was a test to see if you could handle
being my best man and just as I
predicted you failed miserably oh no no
I mean I'm relieved but this is
embarrassing it's okay bud obviously I
prepared for this let's just go have a
nice night I'll buy you a beer 30
minutes GD
we've been trying to pick a bar for 30
minutes it is literally impossible to be
your friend you're incapable of making a
single decision look I know I can be
indecisive but what's the harm in taking
a few extra minutes to find the fun
you